[Música]
he venido a hablaros de como en la era
digital y de las emociones todos
absolutamente todos podemos liderar
nuestro futuro porque todos tú tú sí tú
tú también todos absolutamente todos
tenemos ideas y las ideas es la esencia
de la transformación digital vemos que
el mundo está cambiando es todo está en
pleno proceso de cambio
pero en ese proceso de cambio nos
aportan muchas cosas positivas tenemos
nuevos formatos de interacción de
comunicación de formación de hacer
negocios y también cambian nuestros
hábitos en nuestras costumbres pero eso
está repleto de oportunidades para todos
y cada uno de nosotros de oportunidades
que nos harán despertar nuestras
vocaciones y estas vocaciones nos harán
sacar lo mejor de nosotros mismos o reto
a todos a que intentéis despertar las y
ser felices porque todos tenemos ideas
todos tenemos pasiones ilusiones
ambiciones y por eso si las
materializamos podemos ser felices y
porque me diréis porque os digo todo
esto pues os digo todo esto porque las
ideas que es la base de nuestro
conocimiento y la economía del
conocimiento que estamos viviendo en
estos momentos es el activo más
importante que tenemos todos fijaros ya
que las ideas desde hace muchos años
como pues voy a poner un ejemplo muy
sencillo la fregona
a alguien en un momento dado pensó
necesito algo que me facilite la vida e
inventó la fregona verdad y aún hoy se
está utilizando pues imaginaros si a
raíz de una necesidad cada uno piensa en
cómo resolver las cosas y además lo
hacemos de una manera totalmente
diferente y es verdad que hasta ahora
hasta ahora pues todos en general nos
podíamos pensar que los perfiles
tecnológicos serían los que iban a
formar parte de todo este proceso de
cambio me refiero a los que desarrollan
el software a los que hacen las apps los
que nos hacen las webs es decir a toda
la parte más de picar código no pero los
que no estamos por esa labor
somos los perfiles digitales los que
utilizamos esas herramientas que son las
que nos facilitan la vida y que las
aplicamos de manera estrategia con una
estrategia digital en nuestros entornos
para conseguir nuestros objetivos en
nuestra profesión en nuestra vida
privada allá donde vayamos
y esos perfiles digitales son los que
tenemos todos que aflorar de los que no
somos técnicos porque sois técnicos me
parece fenomenal pero yo no lo soy
con esto que os quiero decir os quiero
decir que inevitablemente si todos
queremos crecer como profesionales y
seguir aportando a la sociedad a nuestra
sociedad tenemos que abrazarnos a la
cultura digital y estar en un proceso en
un continuo proceso de aprendizaje de
aprendizaje de la tecnología también
porque es lo que apoyará nuestras ideas
y las hará realidad
mirar yo como os decía pues no tengo
ninguna no estoy diciendo con esto que
no estuviese una ingeniería de ojo yo no
la tengo yo no soy y no soy ingeniera no
tengo ninguna carrera técnica
tecnológica pero llevo desde los años 90
en el ámbito de las tics
y os podría encontrar contar ahora
muchísimas anécdotas y muchísimas
historias pero os voy a contar una que
vivía en primera persona y de la que me
siento muy satisfecha y es que en el año
2003 sobre el 2003 un grupo de
directivas y empresarias pues que íbamos
a todos los eventos en aquel momento
éramos las más jóvenes y las más jóvenes
pues estábamos bueno pues apoyábamos a
todos las iniciativas de las
asociaciones con perfiles similares pero
tenían un ámbito más político nosotras
las empresarias lo que queríamos era
producir queríamos facturar queríamos
ser más competitivas queríamos crecer y
no había ninguna asociación en ningún
recurso que nos facilitara esas
posibilidades entonces que hicimos
pensar y desarrollamos un entorno
telemático porque sólo nos lo podía
proporcionar la tecnología el hecho de
que para ser más competitivas sin estar
en el mismo sitio ni en el mismo momento
podríamos ser hacer intercambio de
negocios saber dónde estábamos qué hacía
y que hacíamos y de qué manera nos
podíamos ayudar las unas a las otras
asignación el círculo de mujeres de
negocios desde una sin necesidad desde
una idea y después la tecnología la
pusimos a nuestra disposición y fue la
que nos facilitó la implantación de la
idea
porque os digo esto también porque yo
creo y estoy segura y es que hay que
redefinir la la innovación la innovación
no es la tecnología la innovación son
las ideas luego la tecnología nos
acompaña o no pero lo que mueve el mundo
lo que transforma el mundo son todas
nuestras ideas absolutamente todas
y por qué os digo eso también porque si
miramos hacia atrás en las últimas
décadas en las explosiones empresariales
las más interesantes han venido de
empresas que han reformulado su manera
de hacer las cosas y que a facebook
infinidad incluso apple o microsoft
ellos a pesar de que aparentemente
pueden parecer empresas de tecnología
son empresas de ideas porque ellos lo
que hicieron fue redefinir lo que ya
existía y redefinir es liderar redefinir
es liderar
qué me dices que no que no se te ocurre
nada seguro que sí estoy convencida ya
ti también fijaros mi hija cuando tenía
seis años en los años allí en el año
2009 un día llego a casa y me dijo mamá
quiero que me monte es un canal de
televisión por internet igual que la
serie icarly yo dije madre mía me he
perdido algo dijo explícame qué ocurre
de qué va todo esto entonces o no pues
me lo explico y eran tres adolescentes
que emulaban un canal que hacían un
programa de televisión en el salón de su
casa y así gracias a mi hija con sus
ideas es con lo que nació una nueva
línea de negocio de la empresa que tenía
en aquel momento
y con todo esto lo que os quiero
transmitir es que nada está escrito
absolutamente nada
quiero que hagáis un ejercicio mental y
penséis cómo sería vuestro día ideal
como sería vuestro trabajo ideal cómo
sería la vida que os gustaría tener e ir
a por ello porque seguro que lo
conseguiréis
y ya como mensaje final
me preguntaréis y para que no se está
diciendo todo esto no pues sencillamente
lo que quiero es que os marchéis de aquí
sabiendo que todos tenemos ideas todos
todos sabemos hacer algo muy muy bien
que nos haga brillar y nos haga ser
felices y además aportar algo a la
sociedad para que el mundo sea mejor
entonces porque no aprovechase el
momento de la era digital y las
emociones y le dais vuestro futuro
gracias
[Aplausos]